there's a story nobody is talking about
but we will talk about it plus we will
talk about President Obama lying
repeatedly to the American public and
president Trump's gives the most
patriotic events ever in history of
humanity I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
bench Bureau Show
[Music]
so many exciting things happening in the
world we'll get to all of those things
but first I want to make an announcement
this Father's Day we are having a
special livestream this Tuesday June
12th 7 p.m. Eastern god-king Jeremy
boring of The Daily wire will host a
roundtable discussion with me Andrew
Clavin and Michael Mills and will
discuss all the elements and fatherhood
because all of us are fathers except for
Knowles and we can hope that never
happens because my god think of his
children but again that's this Tuesday
subscribers will be able to ask us
questions live if you subscribe that
means you can ask us a question of daily
wire.com and if you're not a subscriber
then you just tuned in to Facebook or
YouTube and watch us all hang out and
everyone else will smoke cigars and I
will laugh at them as they died of lung
cancer so check that out Tuesday June
12th 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific it's
a Lee Weyer calm also I want to say
thanks to our sponsor is over at bull
and branch so as I have mentioned a
thousand times on the show
I suck at sleeping I'm great at a lot of
things I mean I'm just amazing but
sleeping not one of those things
terrible at sleeping and that's why I
really appreciate a good set of sheets
end even know I appreciated a good set
of sheets until I tried a really good
set of sheets over from ball and branch
Boehm branch sheets are made from
organic cotton which means they get
softer every time they get washed and
you buy directly from bull and branch so
you're essentially paying wholesale
prices luxury sheets can cost up to a
thousand dollars in the store bull and
branch sheets are only a couple of
hundred bucks
everybody loves bull and branch sheets
three u.s. presidents plus the latest
person Bill Clinton is sexually
harassing probably sleep on bull and
branch sheets so you can check up on
branch sheets right now and get a
special deal 50 bucks off your first set
of sheets at bull and branch comm
promoted Ben that's bull and branch calm
promo code Ben again these sheets are so
good that we actually threw out of the
rest of our sheets in our house and
bought a bunch of other pairs of sheets
because they are just that good bolt and
branch sheets compro McCoy Ben and get
50 bucks off your first set of sheets
it's bol el and branch comm promo code
Ben go over there and check it out for
the special deal fifty bucks off bull
and branch comm promo code Ben to let
them know that we sent you okay so the
big story of the day is actually
courtesy of the Obama administration so
we've been hearing non-stop from the
media that President Trump is the worst
liar in history his administration just
lies and lies and lies and lies and we
here on the bench Shapiro show have
called balls and strikes when President
Trump says something that I don't think
is true I will tell you that I think
that he said something that is
true and I will hammer him if I think
that he did something wrong I'm happy to
do that because he's the President of
the United States and it is our job to
call the President on the of the United
States when he does something wrong but
one of the things that conservatives
find so incredibly galling about the
media coverage of President Trump is
that the media are so eager to use the
word lie about President Trump in every
possible context but they will refrain
in every possible context from using the
word lie about President Obama and they
did for years well turns out today his
stunning report from The Associated
Press the Obama administration shock of
shocks was lying to the American people
for years on end about helping out the
Iranian mullahs so when we talk about
President Trump lying when media talk
about it usually what they are talking
about his president Trump is fibbing
about his inauguration crowd or
President Trump is fibbing about a note
that he wrote about Donald Trump jr. and
a Trump Tower meeting something like
that something that really has very
little to do with governance per se
President Obama lied about key areas of
American governance in a way that
President Trump never has President
Obama lied repeatedly about Obama care
he said if you liked your doctor you
could keep your doctor that was a
complete lie and he kept lying about it
over and over and over and what's
hilarious is that the media covered for
him at the time I believe it was
PolitiFact that originally said that
that statement was half true and then
three years later when it turns out that
it was a lie all along they called it
their lie of the year which is just
incredible and demonstrates how biased
all of these sources are President Obama
lied repeatedly about his treatment of
illegal immigration he said 22 times he
did not have the executive authority to
unilaterally suspend enforcement of
immigration law and then what did he do
he unilaterally suspended enforcement of
immigration laws
he lied two dozen times about that issue
and the media basically let him get away
with it the Obama administration lied
repeatedly about Benghazi in the
aftermath of the murder of four
Americans in Benghazi and a terrorist
attack a pre-planned parrot terrorist
attack the Obama administration lied and
lied and lied first they lied but they
had not denied security then they lied
and said that the whole thing had been
caused by a YouTube video when it
clearly had not been caused by a YouTube
video they they lied repeatedly they
lied when it came to the IRS the Obama
administration lied on issues of serious
national policy they Trump lies because
that's what Trump does about silly
things on a lot of a lot of issues right
Trump will fib
for example about the Philadelphia
Eagles kneeling for the national anthem
and I'll smack him on it as I did
yesterday show but typically the stuff
that Trump lies about tends to be rather
small potatoes when you compare it to
the actual central policy ramifications
of the stuff that President Obama lied
about today's story from The Associated
Press is the most obvious example so
according to the Associated Press the
Obama administration attempted to
end-around its own sanctions in order to
give cash to the worst terror sponsor on
the planet so while the Obama
administration was pitching the Iran
deal while they were suggesting the Iran
deal was going to be some sort of great
savior of the moderates inside Iran and
at the same time saying that Iran was
not pursuing terrorism they had
sanctions in place but the Obama
administration was attempting to end
around those sanctions and they were
lying to the American people about it at
the time according to the AP quote the
report by the Senate permanent
Subcommittee on investigations revealed
that under President Barack Obama the
Treasury Department issued a license in
February 2016 never previously disclosed
that would have allowed Iran to convert
5.7 billion dollars it held in a bank in
Oman from Omani rial
into euros by exchanging them first into
US dollars if the Omani Bank had allowed
the exchange without such a license it
would have violated sanctions that bar
Iran from transactions that touch the US
financial system so in other words Iran
in order to use its capital has to
transfer has to transform it into Omani
rial these are very difficult to then
transfer into American dollars unless
there's a waiver and President Obama was
secretly pursuing just that sort of
waiver so basically what happened is
that the Obama administration went to a
bunch of American banks and tried to get
American banks to go along with
violations of American sanctions they
issue them a waiver and these banks said
no the bank said listen we don't want to
be caught up in the middle of this we're
not gonna run money for Iran on your
behalf only the fact that US banks did
not want to violate American law
prevented Iran from getting a TENS on
five point seven billion dollars more in
American dollars Senator Rob Portman
from Ohio he says what the Obama
administration misled the American
people and Congress because they were
desperate to get a deal with Iran so at
the same time that Obama was pursuing
this Iranian deal which was a garbage
deal from the very beginning they were
lying to the American people saying the
sanctions were fully enforced and that
they had no intention of becoming money
launderers essentially for the Iranian
regime at the very time they were
attempting essentially money-laundering
from the Iranian regime the Obama
administration repeatedly lied over and
over again about their supposed a
willingness to allow Iran access to the
US financial
system Obama Treasury secretary Jack Lew
even testified before Congress to that
effect which could amount to perjury so
what is Team Obama have to say about the
fact that they were trying to help out
Iran so Iran could avoid sanctions
passed by the United States Congress
held globally what was Obama saying at
the time well they were saying that they
weren't doing it and now what are they
saying unnamed Obama officials according
to the AP said they were acting quote in
line with the spirit of the deal so they
weren't in the acting in line with the
letter of the law they were acting in
line with the spirit of the deal which
is apparently to give away the store and
bend over backwards for the worst terror
regime on the planet they said the lies
were justified because they were
attempting to debunk arguments that team
Obama wanted to get even more
concessions to the Iranians so in other
words people were saying you're bending
over backward from Iran for Iran and so
team Obama lied about bending over
backward for Iran to prove that they
weren't bending over backward for Iran
yeah well done guys and some of my car
doing that Bill Clinton didn't lie about
sex with Monica Lewinsky he just wanted
to debunk rumors that he had sex with an
intern and it turns out the Obama
administration activity on behalf of
Iran went even further in March 2016 is
according to the AP is not a right one
news source according to the Associated
Press in March 2016 Obama officials
including the execrable Secretary of
State John Kerry quote fanned out across
Europe Asia and the Middle East trying
to convince banks and businesses that
could do business with Iran without
violating sanctions and facing steep
fines so the Iranians were complaining
listen you guys want us to sign a deal
with you and we have signed a deal with
you but we're not seeing the benefits of
this deal so why don't you go out there
and act as our PR agents and Team Obama
said sure let's do it let's go out there
let's be around friends well go out
there we will be there foreign ministry
and so the Obama administration was the
foreign ministry for the Iranian
government they talk about collusion
with Russia by the Trump administration
the same Trump administration that has
killed some hundreds of Russians in
Syria the same Trump administration that
is armed Ukrainian resistance with
lethal weaponry they talk about Trump
collusion with Russia
you don't say about collusion the Obama
administration was covertly playing
foreign ministry for the worst terror
regime on planet earth that was covertly
pursuing nuclear weapons as it turns out
there's another story in a second that
I'm gonna tell you the AP continues in
the same week the AP reported that the
Treasury had prepared a draft of a
license that would have given Iran much
broader permission to convert its assets
from foreign currencies into easier to
spend currencies like
yen or rupees by first exchanging them
for dollars in offshore financial
institutions the draft involved a
general license a blanket go ahead that
allows all transactions of a certain
type rather than a specific license like
the one given to a man's bank Muscat
which only covers specific transactions
and institutions the proposal would have
allowed dollars to be used in currency
exchanges provided that no Iranian banks
no Iranian reals and no sanctioned
Iranian individuals or businesses were
involved and that the transaction did
not begin or end in u.s. dollars in
other words they're going to cover this
up as far as it could possibly go but it
was the American government helping out
the Iranian government Obama
administration officials at the time
assured concerned lawmakers that a
general license would not be coming but
the report from the Republican members
of the Senate panel showed that a draft
of the license was indeed prepared that
was never published so in other words
they were pursuing it at the same time
they were lying and saying they weren't
pursuing it when questioned by lawmakers
about the possibility of granting around
any kind of access to the US financial
system Obama era officials never
volunteered that the specific license
for Bank Muscat and Oman had been issued
two months earlier so they lied about
this I mean this is perjurious stuff and
this is criminal stuff and yet the Obama
administration we were told that they
were honest they were clean as the
driven snow just absolutely pure and by
the way is the second deal this week
demonstrating the team Obama lied to
Americans about the Iran deal that
Iran's yield that Obama treasured so
dearly President Obama believed that
Iran should become a regional power by
granting it more power it would moderate
Iran an insane proposal but tied into
President Obama's misconceptions about
the nature of Shia Islam and the Muslim
world in particular and so here is the
second story that is a serious problem
for the Obama administration if anyone
cared in the media on Tuesday and by the
way I should but I should mention of
course the AP is reporting this so it's
not everybody in the media ignoring this
but why is that the media were so happy
to go along with all of these lies for
eight long years in only two years after
Obama leaves office we find out about
this on Tuesday the Iranian government
announced they've completed a new
centrifuge assembly at their Natanz
facility that's just a month after
President Trump killed the Iran nuclear
deal which is sort of suspicious since
we were assured that the Iranians had
dismantled all of their nuclear
capacities that the Iranians were going
to dismantle those nuclear capacities
for the next ten years and they weren't
going to be able to reconstitute their
nuclear program so quickly so here's how
the Obama fanboys in The New York Times
reported this odd development quote
while Ron said it would keep it
enrichment within limits set by the 2015
nuclear accord the center's opening
seems to signal that it could swing to
industrial level enrichment if that
agreement which the United States
withdrew from last month should further
unravel under the 2015 nuclear deal Iran
stopped enriching uranium to the 20%
limit they would allow for rapid
development of a nuclear weapon and
agreed to a limit of under five percent
it will adhere to that limit Iran's
supreme leader Ayatollah Khomeini said
in a speech on Monday yes surely the
mullahs who have been lying for
literally decades about this stuff would
not have lied to the Obama
administration I do love how the New
York Times tries to twist this into well
it's really Trump's fault I've Trump
hadn't pulled out of the Iran deal
they wouldn't fired up the centrifuge
facilities again the real question is
why is it that in a month they were able
to redevelop their centrifuges
I thought these had been dismantled I
was assured that the Iranians would not
simply snap back to a nuclear program
the minute the seal was over by
President Obama I remember him saying it
and yet it seems like that's exactly
what happened that's not the extent of
the lies there more lies than that first
I want to say thanks to our sponsors
over at Barroso you're sitting on a
couch right now listening to my podcast
right well look at that couch like look
at it it's got the stains it's just
terrible it's probably the same so for
your grandmother died on well you don't
want to sleep on that thing anymore you
don't want to lie on that thing anymore
you don't want to sit on that thing
anymore instead what you want is a brand
new sofa that is just awesome and that's
where burrow comes in
hey bro sofas they're handcrafted in the
same factories in North Carolina as
other high-end retailers but burrow
actually delivers them for much less
cost with their innovative award-winning
design they've been Organon eclis
designed to allow for those multi hour
Netflix binges tripleheader game days
late-night work sessions the work
sessions are particularly important for
me because they actually have a USB
charger built into the sofa which is
awesome it's amazing nobody's thought of
this before and you can customize your
Barroso put a mattress style by
selecting the color size armrests height
and leg color that is perfect for you
shipping is fast and free unlike the
rest of the outdated furniture industry
so check it out enjoy 30 days of cozy on
your comfortable burro risk-free or try
out one of them at their partners
showrooms today go customize your own
burro and get 75 bucks off your order by
going to burro calm slash ben shapiro
this bu rrow comm / ben shapiro burrow
comm / ben shapiro for 75 bucks off your
order it's just awesome bro comm / ben
shapiro
okay so the extent of the Obama
administration's lies on Iran are pretty
extraordinary of course their biggest
lie about the Iran deal is that the Iran
deal was pursued because there was an
opening in the
oceans you remember that ben rhoades
remember that guy who is basically
sitting there in stunned silence during
the Trump election and it was hilarious
and wonderful remember that guy well
that guy spent most of the Obama
administration publicly lying about Iran
saying that Iran had now moderated there
was new Iranian regime in place that was
eager to reach out to the American
people and make a deal with the world
that was all a lie he went around
bragging to The New Yorker magazine that
there he'd created an echo chamber
strategy to anybody who would listen
right that he had used people like
Jeffrey Goldberg the new editor over at
the Atlantic who I believe is is it
wasn't pawn and Lackey for the Obama
administration Rhodes basically
suggested the same thing Rhodes said
that we were lying to everybody about
what was going on with you around zeal
they went ahead and did it anyway and
this is why so many people on the right
are so fed up with the media suddenly
getting harsh with President Trump now
listen I wish the media were just as
hard on President Obama as they've been
on President Trump I think the solution
to the media's disproportionate focus on
Trump is to increase its coverage of
Democrats not to decrease its coverage
of Republicans there's this feeling on
the right that turnabout is fair play if
the media was going to ignore all the
bad stuff that Obama did why shouldn't
we ignore all the bad stuff that the
Trump does my feeling is how about we
hold all of our politicians to the same
accounts and when they do bad stuff
let's call them on it but is there a
media double standard absolutely
abso-freaking-lutely there is a media
double standard when it comes to the
Obama administration versus the Trump
administration and this latest spate of
stories regarding Iran is the most
obvious example of this I mean it is
just stunning
it truly is stunning remember Obama was
lying to the American people over and
over again the word lied was never used
with President Obama with regard to
anything go back and look the media
never said that Obama lied about things
they said that maybe he made a mistake
or maybe he exaggerated I mean even this
ap report with his really really damning
ap report at the very beginning of the
report they try to soft-pedal the nature
of the report itself it's really quite
astonishing at the very beginning of the
report here is what the AP actually says
so the report begins with these words
the Obama administration secretly sought
to give Iran access albeit briefly to
the US financial system by sidestepping
sanctions set in place after the 2015
nuclear deal I love those two words
albeit briefly just wonderful I'll be it
briefly can you imagine
saying about Trump Trump fibbed albeit
briefly they would never use that kind
of language with regard to president
Trump because this is how the media
treat Democrats versus how they treat
Republicans Obama gets to run around
saying he had a clean administration
when he absolutely did not now speaking
of this sort of stupidity
last night Stephen Colbert had on Bill
Clinton now as you'll recall Bill
Clinton is the worst so Bill Clinton is
not only a human being who has sexually
harassed half of the women in the United
States he's just as bad about women as
any allegations about Trump ever have
been Bill Clinton in MIT and some of the
allegations are worsening their
allegations rape a credible allegation
of rape against him by one Anita
Broderick Bill Clinton went on NBC's
Today Show and then he got mad at the
interviewer yesterday we pointed this
out he got very upset with the
interviewer instead of waving his bony
finger at the guy and saying how dare
you ask me these questions I apologize
to the entire American people well now
Stephen Colbert is asking Bill Clinton
about all of this but Stephen Colbert
remember a guy who said that President
Trump had been used by Vladimir Putin as
his bleep holster as his genital holster
you remember he said this on national TV
I guess that Stephen Colbert's idea of a
strong interview is to act as precisely
that for Bill Clinton to perform the job
no one but Monica Lewinsky would perform
on Bill Clinton apparently that's what
Stephen Colbert was doing look how he
opens this interview now later in the
interview Colbert says you know you're
the most prominent man in my lifetime to
sexually harass the help but listen to
how he opens this interview with Bill
Clinton I noticed she didn't enjoy that
entire interview I want you to enjoy
this one but I do want to ask you
something which is when I got home last
night on the CNN they had a lower third
banner that said something about William
Clinton's tone-deaf response to the
question from the Today Show my question
is would you like a do-over on that
answer do you understand why some people
thought that was a tone-deaf response to
his questions about the me2 movement and
how you might reflect on your behavior
twenty years ago okay why don't you
stick your hand up his ass and using his
face as a meat puppet I mean as long as
you're going to just feed him the answer
you may as well just be a full
ventriloquist like Stephen Colbert could
have done an interview with Stephen
Colbert dressed as Bill Clinton with
that question I mean that's as bad as
any leading question that was asked by
anybody during the election cycle on Fox
News to Donald Trump okay that leading
question is astonishing the last part of
that question do you understand why some
people thought that was a tone-deaf
response to his question on the meeting
movement here's the part where he feeds
in the answer I love it and how might
you reflect on your behavior 20 years
ago and how that reflection may change
based on what you've learned from the
me2 movement why don't you just give him
the answer
why bother answer asking the question
would you like a do-over imagine that
Donald Trump weren't coming on the show
right now and Stephen Colbert and
Donald's from just an interview about
the sexual harassment allegations and
gotten really grumpy about it and
Stephen Colbert you think Colbert would
lead off with you know mr. president
would you like a do-over
would you like to reflect on how the
media movement has changed your
perspective on these things over the
years or do you think the Colbert one
said yeah mr. president looks like you
weren't too happy with that sexual
harassment question maybe because you
sexually harassed people don't you think
that's what Colbert probably would have
said to lead off that interview and then
of course here's Bill Clinton's answer
because he gets thrown a softball right
over the middle of the plate and he it's
about a single I mean it barely clears
the second baseman's head it wasn't my
finest hour but the important thing is
that was a very painful thing that
happened 20 years ago and I apologized
to my family to Monica Lewinsky and her
family to the American people I'm in at
then a minute now I've had to live with
the consequences every day sense and I
still believe this meeting movement is
long overdue necessary and should be
supported okay so now he believes in the
meeting movement yeah I love that he
comes back and he actually spouts
Colbert's direct answer back at Colbert
yes
great interviewing skills and then you
wonder why people on the right aren't
willing to watch Stephen Colbert why
people on the right are looking at
people like Colbert and saying this is
endemic to the media you wonder why we
don't take the media seriously President
Trump when he says fake me as I've said
this a thousand times I'll say it again
when President Trump says fake news and
people resonates that it's not because
they are just blindly following
President Trump they're doing that
because they didn't like the media in
the first place they figured the media
was lying to them because the media does
lie to them the media plays defense for
Democrats on a regular basis all the
time and then we are supposed to believe
them when suddenly they turn on one
politician in particular at the very
least we're gonna say it's
disproportionate as I said yesterday the
same media who are complaining about
coverage of Hillary Clinton's health
issues was spending in the last week
suggesting that maybe Melania Trump had
been abducted and anally probed by
aliens or something these are the same
people it really is it really is quite
amazing okay so in just a second I want
to get to more fallout from the dis
invitation to the White House by
President Trump of the Philadelphia
Eagles and President Trump holding a
rather hilarious event a patriotic event
on the lawn at the White House to
compensate we'll get into all of it
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsor is over at filter by so I don't
want to seem too much but I suspect that
you have a lot of bills to pay already
and that is why you need to be spending
you know the appropriate amount of money
on your air filters not too much not too
little the appropriate amount and listen
I know you don't want to hear about air
filters right now I know it's not the
sexiest topic but let's be real about
this the reason that you're hacking up a
lung and I could be your air filters the
reason that you're going home you don't
feel so good you feel like you're got
phlegm and you're throwing all this it
could be because you haven't bothered to
clean your air filters in the last
thirty seven years and there's basically
the equivalent of a human body's worth
of ash in your air filter so maybe you
might want to check that out and then
head over to my friends over at filter
by according to the Department of Energy
the most expensive utility for most
Americans is their electricity bill and
you can drop that electricity bill by
getting air filters that actually work
America's leading provider of HVAC
filters for homes and small businesses
available over at filter by they carry
over 600 sizes if you are one of those
difficult people who have to deal with
this stuff they can make custom filters
just for you plus they ship free within
24 hours and if that isn't enough
they're manufactured here in the United
States there's no excuse not to do it
set up auto delivery never have to think
about it again when you save five set
five percent additionally you extend the
life of your system
you don't want to bust your HVAC because
then you're really screwed so go check
it out set up water delivery it makes
life easier as you save five percent as
well save time save money and breathe
better with filter by com filter Bui
comm filter by comm and let them know
that I sent you filter by comm get five
percent off of your auto delivery when
you set that up as well filter by comm
check it out already so president Trump
in in the most bizarre and strangely
hilarious and yet disputing controversy
of the week this would be President
Trump's decision to disinvite the
Philadelphia Eagles so the White House
has an alternative story as to why
President Trump disinvited the
Philadelphia Eagles so the go
story is that the Eagles weren't gonna
show up with enough players Trump got me
out and he cancelled it the White House
story is that the Eagles were basically
jackin them around that it was a setup
ya be hearing this from a lot of
conservatives I just want to say this
okay if you think that President Trump
is constantly being set up by people
there's a way for him to avoid the setup
and that is to just not fall for it yeah
I'm getting kind of tired of the
constant excuse making you know Trump
makes a mistake and then it's well he
was set up to make that mistake okay
guess what every test you ever had in
school was set up to do it was set up to
test you yes it's true President Obama's
political opponents president Trump's
political opponents rather test him on a
regular basis the question is how well
you handle those tests so I'm not saying
the Philadelphia Eagles are Pro Trump
they're not believe the owner Jeffrey
Loria is a wildly left guy but President
Trump could have handled this better no
question but here's Sarah Huckabee
Sanders suggesting that the Eagles were
planning a political stunt now I will
explain in a second what exactly the
White House should have done about it
look if this wasn't a political stunt by
the Eagles franchise then they wouldn't
have planned to attend the event and
then backed out at the last minute and
if it wasn't a political stunt and they
wouldn't have attempted to reschedule
the visit when they knew that the
president was going to be overseas and
if this wasn't a political stunt they
wouldn't have waited until Monday well
after a thousand of their fans had
travelled and taken time out of their
schedules to offer only a tiny handful
of representatives to attend the event
okay so apparently so the idea here is
that they originally said they're gonna
bring a hundred people and then they
said they were only and bring like ten
people and then at the very end it was
only like Nick Folk who is the who's the
quarterback for the team fine fine so
Trump should have hosted Nick focuses on
behalf of the on behalf of your team and
the media would made fun of it and then
he should have said listen I understand
if people don't want to visit the White
House that's their prerogative again
there was a member of the Boston Bruins
back in 2012 who didn't visit the White
House the media ripped him up and down I
mean speaking of media biased media
ripped that player up and down Tim
Thomas was the goalie for the Boston
Bruins they said how dare he not visit
the White House it just demonstrates
what a bad faith guy he is now the
entire Eagles team doesn't really want
to visit in the media's like fine but
how should the White House have handled
it what they should have done is they
should have said listen the White House
is always open to any of these players
who want to visit and if they don't want
to visit you know that's that's really
them missing out because the White House
is an amazing place and we would really
love to see them here but you know we
can have our political differences
which they didn't extend to the sporting
world right being gracious is not the
end of the world and listen again I
understand President Trump is a hammer
in search of a nail and he's constantly
hammering and he's constantly kicking
back I get it I get that this tendency I
don't think he is well served in this
particular case so here is what how
Trump responded so President Trump
responded by saying you know what we
won't have the Eagles will cancel the
Eagles but we'll have a patriotic event
a deeply patriotic event and which will
get the Marine Corps band out here to
play god Bless America and and I will
talk about how much we respect our flag
the problem I have with this of course
is that a lot of the Eagles aren't
showing up because they don't like Trump
personally and don't like his politics
not necessarily because of the kneeling
for the national anthem controversy at
all Trump as I said yesterday lied when
he said that Philadelphia Eagles members
were kneeling for the anthem not one
Philadelphia Eagles member kneeled the
entire year for the national anthem but
here was president Trump yesterday doing
his event saying that he respects the
flag the suggestion of course being that
his political opponents do not respect
the flag I don't like this if you wanna
say Colin Kaepernick doesn't respect the
flag agree if you want to say that you
know the every member of the Eagles who
didn't show up doesn't respect the flag
I don't think President Trump is the
flag I don't think that that this
administration is the flag I hated when
President Obama did the same thing that
he disagreed with him you were
disagreeing with America I hate that
crap it's just nonsense here was
President Trump doing it yesterday with
respect to the flag we love our country
we respect our flag and we always
proudly stand for the national anthem we
always will stand it's about a thousand
people showed up a lot of these people
were White House staffers and White
House interns there were some
Philadelphia Eagles fans who showed up
as well but you know the fact that the
Trump felt they need to do this this
kind of thumb in the eye listen I
understand a lot of people who are Trump
supporters like this sort of thing they
like to B's fighting the culture war I
think it's divisive I think that it's
useless I think it's counterproductive
and then of course it leads to awkward
moments like this so you know if the
ideal is to avoid an awkward moment such
as Trump's they're just with the
quarterback of the Super Bowl winning
team then you could avoid a then you
shouldn't have awkward moments like this
where Trump is standing there and he's
got the Marine Corps Choir standing next
to him flanking him and singing god
Bless America and then it appears he
doesn't know the words
[Music]
okay it's like a big deal that he
doesn't know the words no maybe we had
the same in controversy when he when he
visited a football game uh I was college
football national championship and he
supposedly didn't know the words to the
star-spangled banner and all the rest of
it isn't a big deal no it's not a big
deal it's just I don't like this kind of
showmanship this is not what the
presidency is for it is not an imperial
office it is not a place where you
summon people to meet you and they are
required to meet you it is not a place
where if you don't come to meet the
president then he gets to bring out the
Marine Corps band and imply you're not a
patriot I just I find this sort of stuff
distasteful and you should put the shoe
on the other foot if you disagree if you
think it would been good if Hillary
Clinton had like did you like it when
President Obama shined the rainbow flag
on the White House I thought that was
utterly obnoxious I thought the idea
that you are using the people's house to
push her own personal politics now
you're suggesting that all of America
endorses your view of same-sex marriage
it was gross
it was counterproductive and it
increased the cultural divides that's
why President Trump was elected because
of those cultural divides well by the
same token even if I agree with
President Trump's message about
patriotism I don't like the use of
patriotism as a club to wield against
political enemies particularly when I
don't agree with the idea that everyone
who refuses to visit the White House is
unpatriotic maybe they just don't like
President Trump just says Tim Thomas was
a patriot maybe he just didn't like
President Obama all of these things are
quite possible now with that said do I
think that it's foolish that all these
athletes keep saying they're not going
to visit the White House I do think it's
foolish I understand that listen they
have their prerogative that's fine you
know they don't have to I I would like
to hear their specific beefs with
President Trump as their as their excuse
for doing this but now President Trump
has basically gotten into a culture
where he thinks he can win both sides
think they're winning this culture war
in the end only the American people lose
so president Trump thinks that he's
winning when he's fighting the NFL and
the NBA because in one sense he is most
people agree with him about kneeling for
the national anthem most people agree
with him about patriotism being a part
of our sporting heritage most people
agree with all of that stuff and so he
thinks he's winning on the other side
people on the Left think they're winning
because they think whenever they get in
a culture war with President Trump what
they are doing is winning people over to
their side because President Trump is
personally unpopular so in just a second
I'm going to show you how the NBA and
the NFL how all these people are
responding to President Trump in an
attempt to win more leftist fans I'll
explain that in just a second first how
say thanks to our sponsors over at Tommy
John so Father's Day is coming up we are
right upon it and now is the time to get
your dad a Father's Day gifts that he
will really appreciate I am talking of
course about the best underwear that
money can buy give your dad the gift of
evolved underwear with limited edition
Father's Day gift sets from Tommy John
innovative designs no-brainer features
they've got the time-saving horizontal
quick-draw fly the ingenious stay put
waistband so Sai can roll down on you
and the first of its kind no wedgie
guarantee which I seriously would have
appreciated in junior high in high
school Tommy John cannot be beat they
only use proprietary forward-thinking
fabrics they are soft they're light dad
will swear that he is going commando and
yeah I promise you don't want to check
him on it Tommy John's also got socks
that stay up all day
lightweight undershirts that never come
untucked silky soft second skin t-shirts
that never shrink and so much more their
gear is just fantastic and get all this
stuff for Father's Day plus all of their
underwear is backed by their best pair
he'll ever wear it's free guarantee si
don't have to believe me he can actually
try it out it doesn't like it they can
send it right back so check that out as
a Tommy John customer myself I can tell
you the stuff is really great in as
often as it goes through the wash it
comes out just as good shop
limited-edition Father's Day gift sets
at Tommy John's comm slash apparel right
now and get 20% off your first order
that's Tommy John's comm slash up here
for 20% off Tommy John comm / up here
again you get 20% off your first order
and those those limited edition Father's
Day gift sets are available right now
Tommy John comm / appear oh okay so let
me talk a little bit more about the NFL
plus the story that nobody actually
wants to talk about but probably is the
biggest story of the year decade maybe
we'll talk about that in just a second
you're gonna have to go over to Daly
wired.com to subscribe for all of that
$9.99 a month gets you the rest of this
show live is the rest of clayvin show
live knows the show live and the annual
subscription gets you this the very
greatest in all beverage vessels the
leftist here is hot or cold tumbler it
is magnificent plus more great news for
podcast listeners the Ben Shapiro show
is now available alongside our other
daily wired podcast at Amazon Alexa and
the Google home device so your tone your
home can be filled with my voice at all
times of the day a frightening prospect
I would think but maybe you're into it
with Alexa you have to enable the skill
it's like adding app you say Alexa
enable the Ben Shapiro show skill and
then you can tell Alexa to play or open
you say Alexa play the Ben Shapiro show
Google doesn't need to be added by user
but you have to speak super clearly
again you have to be externally rude to
in order to make this happen you say
okay google talk to the ben shapiro show
or okay google speak to the ben shapiro
show and then you can actually hear the
show and now your device should be able
to play the podcast check out the pin
post on daily wire twitter daily where
facebook if you don't understand how
that works now the reason that you
should subscribe the reason you should
listen so we can also bring you awesome
sunday special so last Sunday we had Joe
Rogan this Sunday coming up we have
jonah goldberg who stopped by to talk
about his new book jonah of course is
the author of the best-selling book the
suicide of the west and we got into a
lot of deep talk so check it out here
here's what it's going to be
hi i'm jonah goldberg and I'm here on
the set with the ben shapiro Sundays
special and tune in to this Sunday for a
pretty interesting conversation where we
talk about almost all of the important
things in the universe it was a lot of
fun and we kept the nudity tasteful and
integral to the plot so check it out it
was it is it is a great episode you're
gonna want to check that out in the
sunday special that's why you should
subscribe over at YouTube subscribe over
at over at itunes that way it just
automatically will download to your feed
and then you'll be able to watch it or
listen to it however you choose to do so
okay you should not obviously get the
subscription okay we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so the NFL controversy of course has
bled over to the NBA where a bunch of
players hate President Trump with a
passion and they're looking for an
excuse to make a headline about how much
they just like President Trump so LeBron
James has decided to comment now LeBron
has a long history of disliking
president Trump he said that President
Trump had revivified rage in the country
and Hayden the country and all this
stuff here is LeBron James saying that
if we win the NBA Finals we will not go
to the White House and then Steph Curry
says the same thing I mean I know no
matter who wins this series no one's
don't wants to invite anyway so it won't
be going said or Cleveland going we have
a lot of freedom in our country and guys
me and our female have the right to do
what they want to do you know in a very
respectful manner and I think if they
decided I want to go to they have the
right so I obviously agree with LeBron
James you have the right not to go to
the White House choosing not to go to
the White House you know that's that's
your problem I'd never problem Tim
Thomas did it with the Boston Bruins I
find this whole controversy very
off-putting and silly I think it's a
waste of time
South Korea said the same thing so for
all those people saying well LeBron is
never gonna go to the White House anyway
he's gonna get swept that's true but
South Korea is saying the same thing I
don't think I think I agree with Bryan
pretty sure the way we handled things
last year kind of stayed consistent with
that but at the end of the day like I
said every team has an opportunity to
make a decision for themselves and and
speak for themselves and and I think
that's powerful okay again I can't
really disagree with the idea that
people have a prerogative not to go to
the White House I think the best way for
Trump to have handled this was as
president just to say listen now I'm the
president we're not gonna do all of this
showmanship we're not gonna do all this
reality TV stuff
I know Trump would probably be not a guy
to embrace that particularly that
particularly muted line but I still
think that that's the way the
president's gotta operate the presidency
is not a showpiece the presidency is not
a place for photo ops the presidency is
not a place where you spend all your
days meeting celebrities and handing
each other jerseys I hate this stuff
I've hated it since the Obama
administration and I continue to hate it
today now meanwhile the President of the
United States is preparing for his big
meetup in in single
or with North Korea and apparently
Dennis Rodman is gonna show up no I'm
not actually kidding about this
apparently he is Kim Jong Un's dear
friend and sources tell the New York
Post there not only will Dennis Rodman
be in Singapore at the time of the
meeting but he could take part in the
negotiations one source told the Post
quote no matter what you might think
about his presence one thing's for sure
the ratings will be huge a lot of times
in situations that involve complex
diplomacy countries like to identify
ambassadors of goodwill and whether you
agree with it or not Dennis Rodman fits
the bill so Rodman of course has visited
North Korea some five times and he
believes that he was responsible for the
North Koreans dictator understanding
Trump in April he told TMZ that he gave
Kim jong-un a copy of Trump's book the
art of the deal for the dictators
birthday in 2017 he said quote I think
Kim didn't realize who Trump was at that
time I guess until he started to read
the book and started to get to
understand him Donald Trump and Kim Jong
learn are pretty much the same well
that's not good I don't think that's
true number one and number two if you
have to use Dennis Rodman as your
ambassador of goodwill if you're trying
not to look like you better come away
with something material here's all I
better say I'm gonna say about this this
North Korean summit you better come away
with something real if you go in and you
have no plan and all that comes out of
it is the second summit at mar-a-lago
where kim jeong-hoon comes to the united
states first of all I think that if Kim
gentleman comes to the United States we
got to strangle him
he's the worst dictator on planet Earth
I think the first opportunity we have to
assassinate him in the leadership of his
regime we should yeah I'm not an
agreement with the Carter Administration
policy that we can't kill foreign
officials it seems to me that people who
are keeping millions of people in a
giant gulag slave state probably deserve
to die Kim jong-un has killed enough of
his own family members to know exactly
what I mean so I'm not a big fan of this
whole this whole thing unless you
actually have a real plan unless you
actually have a serious plan I'm not
getting the the the idea they have a
really serious plan but maybe I'm wrong
maybe Kim jong-un actually wants to come
to the table but it better be worth it
because otherwise it's just gonna be a
bunch of photo op co president Trump
doesn't like bad photo ops and she's
gonna be a bunch of photo ops of Dennis
Rodman alongside Donald Trump and Kim
jong-un and people mocking that from
here til the end of time if they don't
come away with anything material here
it's legitimately like the equivalent of
Ronald Reagan bringing mark the burden
fit rich to negotiations with Gorbachev
I mean if this is important enough I'm
not sure that it ought to be a photo op
for Dennis Rodman Rodman added modestly
I don't want to take all the credit I
don't want to sit there and say I did
this I did
that's not my intention my intention was
to go over and be a sport to ambassador
in North Korea so people understand how
the people are in North Korea I think
that has resonated to this whole point
right now in 2017 when Rodman visited
North Korea he was asked about the
detention of four Americans in North
Korea he said he wasn't gonna mention it
he said that's not my purpose right now
my purpose is to go over there and try
to see if I can keep bringing sports to
North Korea okay so will something come
of this maybe maybe not
color me skeptical I've always been
skeptical of the idea that we got
together with the North Koreans in the
first place it seems like a low-level
diplomacy issue I've never thought that
summits themselves are a diplomatic win
I think diplomatic wins are a diplomatic
win I don't think the meeting with
Hassan rouhani by by John Kerry is a
useful thing I don't think that that
Donald Trump meeting with kim jong hoon
is inherently a useful thing I don't
think meetings between Reagan and
Gorbachev were inherently useful unless
something good came out of those
meetings in the first place
the difference is that at least you
could say the Gorbachev was the leader
of a world power with nuclear weapons
who was threatening the entire security
of the world and so the meeting was a
meeting between two superpowers you
can't say the same thing about this
which obviously grants additional
legitimacy to the Kim regime in in North
Korea so grant ain't granting the sort
of legitimacy I find a little bit
off-putting now meanwhile that we are
hearing some rumors that perhaps there
will be an agenda here perhaps the the
Trump administration knows what they are
doing I'm willing to withhold judgment
because we don't know what they're doing
quite yet but apparently and the idea
here is they're looking for some sort of
timeline on disarmament that's the ideas
that there will be a timeline on
disarmament general mattis the Secretary
of Defense is not going to this John
Bolton apparently is going to this and
they are also looking forward to the
possibility as I say of a second summit
the White House wants him to commit to a
timetable and I guess that they're
looking for the possibility of a second
summit at mar-a-lago commit and came to
a disarmament timetable is not useful
unless there are significant snapback
sanctions in place or unless there's an
end not or and unless there's tremendous
capacity to for us to actually verify
what exactly Kim jong-un is doing in the
first place okay
so now I've been promising it I'll show
the most important story of the day okay
and the story that the media will
largely ignore yesterday The Associated
Press reported that Medicare will become
insolvent in 2026 okay it is currently
20:18 that means in eight years Medicare
will not be able to pay for itself it's
not able to pay for itself right now
it's already running in the read Social
Security is going to follow in 2034 so
within 15 years we are going to see
Social Security essentially go bankrupt
now it's a government program which
means a can't go bankrupt it means
instead they're gonna have to radically
raise taxes or radically reduce benefits
Medicare and Social Security along with
Medicaid do represent the majority of
the federal budget every year so when
you hear about uh-oh we're spending so
much money it's waste fraud and abuse
it's always frightened of you this was
Trump's line it was also the line of
left during the last administration that
you know the way to cut spending was to
look at waste fraud and abuse but we can
never never restructure our key
entitlement programs those are what are
driving our debt those are what are
driving our deficit Medicare and Social
Security as with Medicaid represent a
majority of the federal budget every
year and they are mandatory spending
okay that means you can't change them
unless you actively go and change the
law even in a government shutdown people
get their Social Security checks and
Social Security has been running a
negative cash flow for years if we were
actually to take into account the amount
of unfunded liability we have in
Medicare and Social Security some
estimates say that our national debt is
not 20 trillion dollars it is 90
trillion dollars 90 because we are not
taxing to the necessity necessary to pay
for all of this stuff
my grandmother was paying like 50 bucks
into Social Security 40 years ago 50
years ago now she's taking out thousands
of dollars that's not because they
invest it in the stock market that's
because they're taxing me thousands of
dollars for my grandmother if I want to
help out grandma that's my
responsibility but it shouldn't be my
responsibility to help out your grandma
one of the things that Social Security
has done is that it has shifted the
burden of responsibility from
individuals and families to the
government there's actually been a net
negative it's meant that people feel
less a necessity to take care of their
parents they figure the government is
going to do it and really the government
isn't doing it because the government
doesn't have its own money supply the
government is just taxing my kids in
order to pay for their great grandmother
and not just their great grandmother
somebody else's great grandmother as
well the original ratio with regard to
Social Security like the number of
people who are taking out of secure
social security compared to the number
of people paying in it was like one
person Social Security taxes were paying
for 12 to 15 people today it is to your
Social Security taxes are paying for two
people soon it will be one soon it will
be a direct monetary transfer from my
kids to old people to old baby
by the way are the wealthiest cohort in
the United States as you get older you
get richer so you are taxing people who
are poor to pay for people who are rich
it is actually a regressive policy as
you get older you have more money you
have more assets you have a house you've
been earning for 50 years and yet the
idea is you're gonna tax people who are
not yet born in order to pay for all of
this and yet politicians of both parties
are unwilling to look this right in the
face right the only politician who
really talked about entitlement reform
over the last several decades has been
Speaker of the House Paul Ryan but he's
basically been shellacked for it Donald
Trump ran promising not to touch
entitlements and so he has not
Republicans are in control right now if
they do nothing about entitlements that
is a giant fail on the part of
Republicans because we're gonna feel the
brunt of this and then it will come down
to Democrats saying do you want to raise
taxes and Republican Sainz you want to
cut benefits the estimate is that if we
do not actually raise taxes dramatically
then when the social security fund goes
insolvent when Medicare goes insolvent
you're gonna have to cut benefits by 20%
my feelings of that is okay well I guess
that's the way it's gonna have to be
because I don't see why my kids should
be put behind the economic 8-ball so
that my parents won't have to won't have
to get as much money out of Social
Security I just I don't see why that
should be I'll pay for my parents that's
my responsibility and my parents will
pay for themselves that's their
responsibility so again there are only a
few solutions here we could increase the
payroll tax right now from whatever it
is eleven point seven percent to
something like 14 or 15 percent or we'll
have to cut cost of living adjustments
or he might have to confiscate cash from
people you know people who paid into
Social Security but they're more wealthy
they just won't get anything out of
Social Security or we could raise the
retirement age which is really what we
ought to do right we ought to raise the
retirement age because the reality is
that retirement I don't think is
actually particularly good for people
and retiring at 65 made sense in an era
when the average age of death was 63 it
doesn't make a lot of sense in the day
when the average age of death in the
United States is now over 80 for women
in just about 80 for men that's 15 years
Social Security is supposed to pay for
you delaying retirement and moving their
terminate job
seems like it would make more sense than
all this but we're not gonna say we're
not gonna focus on any of these problems
we're just gonna fight useless stupid
culture wars because that's what we do
now right that's so that's what we are
more involved with but this is what we
should be a paying attention to if the
government was designed for anything is
to solve problems exactly like this and
yet because of the gridlock in our
system which is usually a good thing in
this case a bad thing
it means that we're probably gonna do
nothing kick the can down the road until
that can ends up exploding in our face
okay time for some things that I like
and then some things that I hate so
things that I like I just I had to laugh
at this so nature is red in tooth and
claw as the saying goes and this is
obvious so this family decided that you
can see the small kids they decided that
they were going to raise a caterpillar
into a butterfly so they let the counter
but they fed the caterpillar it's like
The Hungry Caterpillar I fed the
caterpillar and they and they let it
spin its cocoon and then it turned into
a butterfly and finally they were ready
to release it into the wild and then
something unexpected happened okay if
you can't see it and release the
butterfly the butterfly took about three
flaps of its wings and the family dog
ate the thing boom I tweeted out that
this basically was the narrative of the
2016 election that the media fed Hillary
Clinton and they bathed Hillary Clinton
and they wove a cocoon for Hillary
Clinton and they ensured that Hillary
Clinton would never be challenged and
then just as she began to spread her
wings along the lumps the family dog
Donald Trump and eight Hillary Clinton
and that is basically the story of the
2016 election in one hysterically funny
nature video also this demonstrates
again everybody has this romantic view
of nature nature is trying to kill us
okay the the civilization was built to
avoid nature just I know you're sitting
there shaking your head because you love
the nature you don't love the nature
enough they're gonna sleep in that tent
every night okay the nature is trying to
kill you nature's been trying to kill
you for years half of human life is
about trying to avoid nature trying to
murder you so if you want to go out and
like vacation with a trick is nature's
the bad boyfriend all right that's your
thing but let's stop trying to pretend
the nature is kind and cuddly and cute
and friendly okay that dog is a wolf
deep down and that's a like seat the
family butterfly that's what's going on
right there
sounds pretty spectacular okay other
things that I like so every McDonald's
in the United States is going to have
self aura kiosks by 2020 according to
CEO Steve Easterbrook 1,000 stores will
get the new kiosks every quarter for the
next few years there exist in thirty
five hundred of the roughly 14,000
domestic outlets so fight for 15 guys
it's not like McDonald's will come up
with a solution where they replace your
stupid job with a with a machine right
like jobs that are pretty easy to
replace with machines and then you won't
have to worry about people spitting in
your food it's not
like McDonald's we'll just do that
McDonald's these machines are going to
replace everybody ello in low-level jobs
is one of the reasons why there's now
talk of how do we retrain people what do
we do for people who have low skill sets
you know do if menial jobs go away how
do we handle all that but if you keep
artificially boosting the price of labor
particularly entry-level jobs McDonald's
is just going to substitute a bunch of
machines a four-year job Easterbrook
told CNBC that customers who use kiosk
tend to browse the menu in order more
food he said if you think about only two
years ago if you were a customer there
were two ways you can get served in
McDonald's you walk to the front counter
and lined up and took your drink and
find a table or you go through the
drive-through we're introducing many
options they can order through mobile
they can come curbside we'll run it out
as well as the existing traditional ways
you can pay in different ways and
customize your food in different ways
first of all this is better service and
they're not just saving money they're
making life better for you can you
imagine how awesome that is that now
like I order out from restaurants all
the time because my wife you may have
heard he's a doctor that means she has
not cooked dinner in 1,000 years okay so
she is cook that I've cooked more
dinners than she has feminists in the
audience okay so my wife doesn't cook
dinner all that often when she does it
as a pleasure she's an excellent cook
but it has not happened since I was but
a wee pup and that's why we order out a
lot so it would be great if the kosher
restaurants that I went to had the
capacity to run the meal out to the curb
for me because I have two kids who are
screaming in the back and I can't
abandon them in the back of the back of
the car so good out of McDonald's the
service is getting better it's getting
cheaper technology is awesome so by all
means leftist continue to push her
stupid fight for 15 nonsense and watch
as McDonald's replaces you with a
computer so there's that also I have to
enjoy this Howard Schultz in the the
former head of Starbucks he just stepped
down he says that he the Democrats are
moving too far to the left he wants to
run for president in 2020 because what
better to represent the Democratic Party
than a latte sipping liberal from
Seattle he says that he he's ripping the
Democrats an interview on CNBC he
suggested the Democratic Party needs a
leader who won't let it fear to fire the
left now this is true I agree with
Howard Schultz unfortunately not gonna
happen
unfortunately the Democrats have moved
into their own populist mode where
they've embraced the left-most
perspective on everything which is why
Chris Matthews is upset with the elitism
in the Democratic Party he thinks that
they need more grassroots
down-home feel they need more Bernie
Sanders endemic
party cuz Matt Gavin the money Today
Show come on you're all rumpled
hey you know I'm here anyone talking
about that Haiti wheats sure my
boyfriend's in the entire hotel chain
tribes super wealthy but he leaves are
just the worst of garbage you need we
need less elitism in the Democratic
Party Gore's back go a true Democrat
lowercase D thinks they're no better
than anybody else
that's what Democrat is and when the
party regains that with white black
Hispanic people everybody starts to
think of themselves as one of them
instead of being better than them
they'll get back to the party other
people and they're not there yet okay
and this accusing rises in the
background as he makes this populist
speech and there's the upshot with the
light right behind him so you get them
in aerobic profile Chris Matthews when
we start to realize that we're the party
of the people I hate the part of the
people nonsense you know why because
every perspective appeals to some people
okay maybe the elite perspective on this
meaning that you shouldn't run to the
Bernie Sanders left maybe that
perspective is right and one of the
things that I really dislike about the
talk will be leads is that we have not
actually distinguish between elites and
elitism okay if you are elite this means
you are good at something right LeBron
James is in the elite basketball player
what I prefer to watch a non elite
basketball player would you prefer to
watch me clang 7-footers probably not
because being elite at something is
actually a good thing if you are elite
in the business of economics you know
what economics looks like if you are
elite in the in the perspective giving
business it's because you are
entertaining and hopefully knowledgeable
and have a perspective to contribute if
you are elite in politics presumably you
are good at it hey elitism is a
different thing elitism is I'm bossing
you around now that's the stuff we
should all be railing against right left
and center is the idea that we had to
boss each other around that's stuff I
hate that's not what Chris Matthews is
saying he's saying that if you think
that your perspective is better and that
perspective entails for example more
freedom not less then maybe you're an
elitist maybe you're elite maybe it's
got guy here remembers show ho deal okay
time for time for a thing that I hate
so for the second time in just two weeks
there's a black woman screaming at
somebody on the subway that has made
news so this is a crazy video uploaded
to YouTube last week and it shows an
encounter between two passengers on the
New York City subway system actually you
know what this may be the same no this
is not the same video it's it's a
different video so this is so this woman
gets on the subway and the end this
unidentified black woman can be seen
verbally abusing an Asian passenger
according to law and crime calm who she
claims stole her kids seat okay this is
the same exact setup as a video the
reason I'm getting confused there was a
setup last week I talked about and which
a black woman got on the subway and
people didn't stand up for another black
woman and this first black woman started
ripping into the Jews okay in this
particular case this black woman gets
angry and starts ripping into the Asians
because this unidentified mother starts
verbally abusing an Asian passenger who
she claims stole her kids see mother
proceeded to curse her out push her on
the ground and accuse her of not giving
up the seat because her daughter is
black two children could be seen seated
next to the Asian woman so in other
words this Asian woman is sitting there
with her kids which you are supposed to
do when you have kids because they're
trying to keep track of your kids and
here's what the video sounds like
[Music]
she said well you got me effed up
welcome to America F your home put my
effing child out of a seat and then she
realizes that she is being recorded and
then she and then she says what you're
recording my bleep in your mouth so she
sounds like a charming person says she
put she said she put my child out of
seat this ain't your country welcome to
America the reason that I point this out
is not because I think that this is
endemic to any particular race in the
United States the point is that it's not
okay a lot of the talk in the last
election cycle is about xenophobia on
the part of white people in the United
States this idea that white people in
the United States in blanket fashion
thought this was their America and when
Donald Trump said make America great
again what he really meant was make
America white again
the reality is though too many people
have a tribal tendency okay it's
something we all have to fight it
actually is a tendency in us from when
we are children there's tribal tendency
that says my tribe is more important
than your tribe using purported
victimization as an excuse to be a nasty
human being to other people on the basis
of group identity makes you a nasty
person it makes you a bad person okay
this woman is a bad person suggesting
that this is not an Asian woman's
America because I'm a member of one
group and you're a member of another
group is really gross and pretending
that it's not racism because it comes
from one group as opposed to another
group is also really gross bad behavior
is not unique to any one group racial or
ethnic in the United States it is
possible among all groups and we all
have to be careful of letting our own
perception of victimhood turn into
victimization of others we all have to
be careful of allowing our tribal
identities to overcome our treatment of
each other as individuals okay we'll be
back here tomorrow with much more i'm
ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018